so is Ryan coming to your party uh I
think so yeah
hm why oh nothing I mean I have heard
Ryan bash your parties in the past but
it's nothing he's bashed my parties mhm
that I don't know who he thinks he is
because my parties are incredible and
he's one of the worst party guests that
I've ever
known to say hi to us one
like is
not be me it is not going to be you're
the one whose name is on the project
it's going to be you I'll just tell them
that
you pay me back you just cheated me out
of my money what kind of friend are you
so over
it 48 more comments don't mind if I
do can I tell you
something you know how Shannon is
married to John right I saw her leaving
the bar with some dude I'd never seen
before where does he get off I my
parties are good oh your parties are
great he's one of the worst party guests
I've ever known he is not level shows up
what a he going around I don't know
where he gets off I'm I mean he's right
there you should go confront him yeah
hey Ry you piece of
[Music]
a